E aí
[Música]
e no dia três de março deste ano dia que
eu sair do meu reality show do mundo eu
conheci uma nova realidade
uma realidade completamente diferente
de tudo que eu já tinha vivido de tudo
que eu já tinha conhecido principalmente
antes de entrar na casa mais vigiada do
Brasil o Big nos Bis
começava ali havia uma experiência que
impactou profundamente a minha vida
o meu jeito de pensar e principalmente a
minha história de vida eu posso te
afirmar
que a realidade que eu conheci após a
saída do reality Foi algo que eu nunca
vi a passado nem de perto
e eu só não sabia o quanto tudo aquilo
ele impactar minha vida e a minha forma
de seia a saída do reality show era o
fim de um jogo mas também para mim era o
começo de uma nova jornada marcada por
reconhecimentos
aprendizados e grandes mudanças
sobretudo mudanças internas assim hoje
que se passaram sete meses após a minha
saída do Big Brother eu tô aqui para
dividir com vocês o que de fato eu
aprendi com peso do cancelamento e
compartilhar também um pouquinho aí as
formas que eu encontrei para lidar com
tudo isso que aconteceu na minha vida
tem uma alegoria muito conhecida na
filosofia que retrata muito bem o que eu
vivi com a saída do bebê e ao lembrar
dela eu vim compartilhar aqui com vocês
que é o mito da caverna o mito da
caverna na vida de pessoas que saíram e
após um longo tempo vivendo ali várias
sombras de um mundo real
após saírem são
colocadas no primeiro contato com a luz
solar que ofusca a visão e isso
obviamente gera um grande incômodo
após se acostumarem Podem perceber a
grandeza desse Novo Mundo Foi isso que
eu vivi Por mais que você imagina que o
que tá acontecendo lá fora
E é só quando você sai que a realidade
de fato se coloca e ela é posta para
gente com muita clareza aqui fora o jogo
revelado em toda a sua verdade em toda a
sua clareza seja ela positiva ou
negativa era realidade não adiantava
fechar os olhos criar um mundo
imaginário Um Mundo Paralelo ou até
mesmo negar a própria realidade não
fazia o menor sentido pelo menos para
mim né era esconder ou negar o brilho do
sol eu não sou mulher de legal o brilho
do sol dos meus amores isso não fazia
sentido para mim
o mesmo que o brilho do sol pudesse ser
insuportável aos meus olhos Bom muitos
de vocês provavelmente
assistiram acompanharam tudo que rolou
ficaram sabendo sobre todos os
acontecimentos da casa aquela casa que é
extremamente vigiada 24 horas por dia
diariamente 37 milhões de pessoas
acompanham tudo o que acontece ali é
como se toda a população do país Canadá
por exemplo de um país como Canadá
parasse para assistir um programa de TV
soma-se a isso quatro bilhões de
visualizações nos perfis das redes
sociais do reagir e além do mais toda
aquela propagação dos canais Paralelos
nas rádios as revistas os blogs que
acabam de fundindo compartilhando tudo
que tá acontecendo na casa na prática é
assim você pode parar uma pessoa de
forma aleatória nas ruas eu perguntar
para ela ou o parceiro você acha da
Alumina quando você fazer uma pesquisa
no Google a palavra lumena
apontou como resultado aproximadamente
ali quatro milhões de vezes de clique de
busca de pesquisa tudo isso me levou a
uma conclusão né que acontece no BBB
Definitivamente não fica no leve ao
contrário fica no Twitter Nos
comentários das redes sociais
dos Famosos memes Nos programas de rádio
na TV
o e tranquilamente na opinião das
pessoas
se um dia você for participar do BBB
Pega a visão em saiba que isso é uma
realidade
Neste jogo que mistura ficção e
vilania vilões e heróis
narrativas e fatos valores e até mesmo
blitz na verdade são histórias
histórias de diferentes pessoas com
vivências singulares cada um ali no seu
corre nas suas subjetividades que estão
ali por livre e espontânea vontade de se
expor e mostrar para o mundo suas ideias
e seus valores
suas crenças suas intimidades
né e obviamente também seus erros os
dias foram se passando nos dias
posteriores à eliminação foram muito
intensos para mim eu estava tentando
entender tudo o que tinha acontecido
catando informação daqui cartão de
informação da Lei dentro e fora da já
vivenciei obviamente perda o número
muito significativo de feira de
seguidores recebi mensagem de amigos
próximos perguntando Lu mas quem era
aquela lumina ali dentro da casa eu não
conhecia aquela lumina bom
vocês podem imaginar tudo isso me afetou
de maneira muito profunda e me conduzir
um processo de autocrítica reflexão ou
que horas e mais horas assistindo ali as
minhas atuações
ouvindo as opiniões dos Brothers sobre
mim e claro né você sente comentários da
mídia e da galera ali estava meio
próxima das pessoas também internet
transparência muito complexa muito
difícil mas era um caminho inevitável e
sem volta se o meu objetivo era
realmente entender eu precisava fazer
isso aí fui fazer meu corre né
e Sabia que não seria
enfrentando o mundo ou tentando oh
reafirmar as minhas atitudes justificar
é uma melhor forma x ou Y na minha
cabeça eu tinha a consciência de que o
anulamento ou silenciamento que a
cultura do cancelamento pode
proporcionar de fato ali de maneira
prática era um processo muito destrutivo
quase deveriam realmente lutar com uma
menina que já enfrentou grandes
problemas e grandes dificuldades assim
ela usa uma história de vida aqui cabe
sim um alerta para vocês assim de
coração Infelizmente o número cada vez é
cada vez mais crescente de pessoas que
sofrem algum tipo de Humilhação ou
vergonha virtual isso tem gerado
muitos efeitos na minha opinião
extremamente demais tá dores assim tem
dados que com podem comprovar isso
segundo a agência Brasil todos os dias
uma celebridade ou influenciador digital
é cancelado na internet Oi é muito um
objetivo que essas pessoas sejam
anuladas né Vim sim um processo de
aniquilamento mesmo e sofreu um pedaço
de seguidores de fãs
contratos e principalmente a reputação
vão a cultura do cancelamento ele é o
reflexo de uma super exposição né e
obviamente de um mecanismo que tem a ver
com expressões de colocações seis por
não é publicamente o mundo das pessoas
hoje na nas redes sociais atualmente ao
se expressarem podem produzir opiniões
comportamento de anjinhos e isso
obviamente pode
trazer algumas consequências dentro do
que a gente pode considerado que seja
politicamente socialmente incorreto são
bilhões de comentários que convergem
para 10 construir a credibilidade e
colocar o cancelado em umas e não de
vergonha pública você sabe isso tenha
acontecido isso demanda muito frequência
incluir uma inversão Total Da Lógica o
espaço que deveria ser um Palco para
elogios e valorizar a sua imagem a
cotação é um pla mente usado para
humilhar pessoas têm um filósofo que o
filósofo francês Jacques derrida ele
ilustra muito bem o tema ao dizer que é
o grito da modalidade para se expor ou
para expor comportamentos sociais
politicamente incorretos por meio de
palavras e atos
sim deve dar ele faz uma comparação com
grito né um grito que eu escutava
claramente estava disposta a entender
profundamente
uma das primeiras ações foi diferenciar
o grito dos haters embora me assustasse
né é mas eles estavam ali somente para
deixar lá ódio e isso foi importante
saber separar o grito das pessoas
sensatas que não aprovaram as minhas
atitudes no Big Brother e tá tudo bem o
exercício de me colocar no lugar do
outro para perceber seus pontos de
vistas também como escutar as críticas
que foram Três Ilhas foi um caminho
muito importante para poder repensar
tudo que eu tinha feito dentro da casa e
que provocou obviamente reação uma uma
série de reações nas pessoas separei
aqui quatro pontos que me ajudaram a
repensar as minhas ações e me
transformaram transformar a minha
jornada após a saída do riacho a
primeira delas é
ter rede de acolhimento gente rede de
apoio nossa assim minha vida antes de
entrar na casa era cercada por pessoas
incríveis né de esportes e não somente
me inspirava né como eu sempre coloquei
isso muito claro mas também minha
colinho né e minha religião por exemplo
as pessoas me abraçaram né coleiro elas
souberam
separar muito bem as coisas a minha
religião é o ambiente as pessoas me
conhecem e por isso eles puderam me
oferecer um suporte o verdadeiro suporte
que eu tava precisando naquele momento
Claro havia orientações e conversas
muito francas né mas principalmente
tinha muito amor e muito acolhimento
sincero e isso fez muita diferença para
poder tomar combustível penso que
poderia ter aplicado esses ensinamentos
né dentro da casa mas no momento ali do
jogo as coisas são muito de São muito
difíceis as coisas são muito
desafiadoras para a gente muito confusas
então eu me perdi um pouco
e agradeço muito essas pessoas que me
estenderam a mão quando eu mais precisei
e isso eu vou levar para o resto da
minha vida o ponto 2 o que eu poderia
chamar de
um estágio emocional eu acredito que uma
das maiores experiências de aprendizado
veio com um conceito muito nobre que eu
conheci com a fala das alecão uma
comentarista gay de um dos canais mais
conservadores dos Estados Unidos a a Fox
News a Sally ela vive em cia diariamente
uma extrema né uma experiência de
destruímos
Diante do cenário tenso que ela vive
assim
mostrar que podemos discordar sem por
cento do posicionamento e dos valores de
algumas pessoas
e
ela mostra também que a gente não é que
a gente pode ser contra todas as
atitudes e os dados mas quando a um
compromisso é uma um sentimento de
compaixão a um ambiente em que existe
diálogo o diálogo se faz possível e isso
é ser é emocionalmente correto algo que
não fui por diversos motivos que talvez
eu nunca vá compreender muito bem pior
que eu
é mas eu acredito que o nosso desafio
como pessoa é sempre mas sempre conectar
a eu sempre se conectar emocionalmente
com os outros
mesmo que elas pensem diferentes ou de
uma forma diferente Ou vivem-se
situações
completamente
antagônicas a nossa a terceira
experiência transformadora
que veio a partir da minha do meu
processo né da minha tomada de
consciência e do meu processo de
reconhecimento sobretudo voltados os
meus atos realizados dentro da casa Foi
sim é
uma experiência de
interpretar e reconhecer que os erros
que eu cometi principalmente algumas
pessoas tinham impactado de maneira
muito negativa né hoje eu consigo
perceber claramente mas dentro da casa
eu não conseguia ver que Alumina que
tava ali era uma e ela tinha outra essa
compreensão que o que o meu
comportamento dialogava com com essa
dimensão de cancelar o outro e foi isso
que o público fez comigo a partir do
momento que eu comecei a agir assim aqui
fora né Foi muito interessante perceber
esses dois cenários mais do que o
reconhecimento das minhas atitudes assim
que eu já percebia logo ao sair da casa
eu buscava entender os porquês eu
precisei acessar e fundo por que que
tava acontecendo tudo aquilo e foi assim
que nós tá espiral quase por alguma
coisa que entender e buscar as soluções
quisesse sentido assim para mim eu sabia
que era preciso ter maturidade para
digerir e reconhecer e principalmente né
reparar os danos tem sido Gerais se
fosse possível né para conseguir seguir
uma nova jornada uma jornada muito mais
leve aqui fora e aqui está a forma como
eu penso se eu acredito em algo E se o
que eu falo está em concordância com o
que eu faço devo sim expressar as minhas
ideias
falar as minhas verdades
mesmo que muitas pessoas tenham opiniões
contrárias e isso possa me custar caro
né num dado momento da minha vida se
agredir tem alguém eu luto por essa
pessoa
mas se por algum motivo eu entender e a
conhecer que meu comportamento né ele tá
ali
ser interpretado como errado ou
minimamente incorreto e não são mais
coerentes né com um novo entendimento
eu acho que eu tenho a liberdade para
mudar
e reiniciar Uma Nova História na
psicologia
chamamos isso de
ressignificação que é definida como uma
busca de Olá queridos
para a vida os aspectos dela acaba sendo
fundamental esse exercício né É
fundamental e o mundo que exige de nós a
todo momento
constantes construções reinvenções e
produções de novas narrativas eu posso
dizer assim do fundo do meu coração que
existe Alumina antes do BBB a lâmina
durante o programa e o Alumina após tudo
isso que aconteceu o que não muda em
todas essas meninas para mim é Ciência a
mas o público percebe essas mudanças às
vezes vocês podem perguntar você
questionar sim o meu público ele tá
atenta Tudo Claro a coerência é dos atos
ao longo do tempo é isso que vai
sustentar essa percepção e eu prezo
muito isso mas hoje Particularmente eu
recebo milhões e comentários positivos
de pessoas que antes né o ácaro em dado
momento neste mundo nada do que eu vi
venceu hoje né que é uma super exposição
a gente vê carreira sendo ameaçadas mas
também estrelas sendo reveladas E isso
não jogo uma história de pessoas reais e
recebe críticas
e eu também recebe elogios Regência seus
atos e não é ninguém que esteja levar
isso essas críticas a esses
questionamentos aquilo que aconteceu no
passado será usado contra você a
qualquer momento Nem adianta achar que
não por isso acaba sendo fundamental a
gente tem essa capacidade de
ressignificar e obs ter coragem para
mudar para mudar sempre né sempre quer
um novo entendimento sobre os nossos
próprios atos e as nossas falas bom as
amores Último Ponto e compartilhar com
vocês é essencial é que foi através
deste entendimento que eu consegui
reconstruir a minha jornada né
Principalmente a minha jornada após o
reality show
tem um autor que eu gosto muito brene
Brown que ele tem uma frase que diz
assim a vergonha não pode O que é
empatia com o cancelamento eu vivi
situações às quais Eu particulamente não
desejo para ninguém assim né nem para os
meus inimigos
tristeza ansiedade
alteração de sono isolamento tudo o que
de ruim que geram desconforto consigo
mesmo eu vivi aqueles dias assim ele
foram são memórias muito ruins ainda
muitas pessoas se perguntam assim e me
pergunto será que você se arrepende de
tá indo para o vi Alisson eu sempre
costumo responder e hoje de maneira
muito mais convicta que a resposta não
não me arrependi nada gente foi os
parecer transformadora para mim e eu
amei participar de viagem eu agradeço
inclusive muita oportunidade né de ter
participado e inclusive arrisco dizer
que participaria outras vezes até porque
eu vivi momentos únicos e eu reconheço
que foram essenciais encontro
contribuições para o meu amadurecimento
para o meu reconhecimento sobre os erros
mas sempre continuar a resposta dizendo
que eu me arrependeria sim de ter
participado se após a minha saída da
casa aí tem vivenciado todo o anulamento
ou silenciamento fosse maior que a minha
capacidade de reconhecer os meus erros e
aí sim constroem novas narrativas
juntamente com vocês tão bom meus amores
a minha conclusão é que é isso é só mais
um início de uma nova jornada
melhor do que a que eu terminei anterior
e sim temos a capacidade de um
significado de nossas próprias histórias
Então pega essa visão
é um abraço e
E aí